hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the six
meditation after he has concluded that
there is an external world and that I do
have a body based on considering the
nature of two of our faculties that of
imagination an active faculty and
Sensibility a more passive Faculty both
of which only really make sense if we do
in fact possess a body and engagement
with an external reality something
outside of our minds something that is
as he says extended incorporeal the curt
is going to say something quite
interesting and important he says there
is no doubt that everything nature
teaches me contains some truth and this
is not to say that everything is exactly
the way that that what we're going to
call nature in just a moment portrays it
to us as a matter of fact we have to be
a little bit careful sometimes not to
mix things up but there's some truth in
it there's something that we can rely
upon so if you think about the Cartesian
project in general not only do we want
to have the fact that yes I have a body
and there's an external world of other
bodies that that you know I'm engaged
with in some way we want to know more
about what we can call the that you know
the details the nitty-gritty whether
things are as I
perceive them to be or imagine them to
be so first we have to think about what
he means by nature what is it to be
taught by nature he talks about nature
in two different ways here he says by
nature considered in general I don't
understand anything other than God
itself or himself do you mem right so we
could think about the the marks that God
has placed within the mind I says as a
workman does to his product you know the
very idea of God is a perfect being or
other things that God would have taught
us in that way perhaps by supplying the
storehouse of consciousness which we'll
get to in just a moment or he says the
order and disposition that God has
established within created things so if
we think about the universe as a
totality insofar as it is a created
universe we can know things about it and
we can know about the arrangement the
connections between things so this opens
up the door for doing what Descartes is
really interested in which is science
natural science Descartes was very
interested in mathematics in geometry
but it was very interested as well in
what we would nowadays call physics and
biology so this opens up the possibility
that nature teaches us all sorts of
things by way of showing us things about
the order and disposition of created
things he also talks about my nature in
particular and he says what that is is
the complexion or the assemblage of all
the things that God has given me and
complexion don't think about you know
the way things look on your face or
anything like that it's really just a
french translation of complex you in the
Latin and this comes from the word for
you know comas is together and
plaque theory is is folding so the way
things are unfolded together the way
things are connected together think of
cause and effect and other connections
resemblance all those sorts of things
and the the assemblage the ways in which
things have been you know heaped up you
might say what's what's in there what's
not what does God given us God has given
us our various faculties intellection or
understanding volition imagination
memory sensation the capacity to feel
emotions all of these things which are
types of thought are things that God has
given us the entire store house of
innate ideas that Descartes says we can
grasp the true and immutable nature's of
in meditation five would also be things
that consist in my nature in particular
things that that God gave me how does
this help us when it comes to the
external world well this is where nature
teaches us all sorts of things I should
point out as well that the current has a
little bit of a digression a little bit
later where he talks about things that
we know without the intermediary of the
body things that we we know just from
the mind itself and its workings so
these are he calls these truths that are
known by the illumination of the natural
light looking at them these are things
that we you know provided were using our
intellects properly and not substituting
imagination for it we should be able to
do so you know he says one of the one
example of this is that what was done at
one point in time cannot no longer not
have been done right so logical truths
we could say right but if we get away
from those and we talk about well what
else does nature teach us what else does
my nature in particular or the nature of
the universe in general teach us as
human beings
one of the AZ set
says that there's nothing that this
nature teaches more expressively or more
sensibly than the fact that I have a
body Jeon core right which is badly
disposed when I feel pain which has a
need to eat or to drink when I have the
feelings of hunger or thirst and he says
I can't doubt that there is some truth
in this it might not be that hunger is
exactly what I'm picturing itself when
I'm picturing it to be to me you know we
have all these nice metaphorical terms
for hunger and feeling hunger pangs my
my stomach is upset you know I have this
gnawing inside of me right it's like a
wolf is is tearing at me from the inside
okay all those are essentially images
that we use to to convey something
they're not actually what we're feeling
but there is some truth there there is
something going on there's a total
digression we now know that there are
some things that are analogues to to
brain cells within the gut and so
perhaps if Descartes were around today
and finding that out
he might be inclined to say well perhaps
there's some mind-body connection going
on
in terms of the elementary canal as well
going on with this he says nature also
teaches me by these very sentiments of
pain hunger and thirst that I'm not only
lodged in my body like a pilot in a ship
but beyond that I am conjoined with it
very closely plays they taught them all
in French and so mixed up with it coal
fondue and and men a and in this that I
compose a single hole with it I'm not
just a mind and a body one over here one
over here there's no over here by the
way for mines they're not incorporeal
non spatial but I'm not just a mind in
the body
I am the unity
I am the whole that is that mind and
body together so he says if this wasn't
the case that when my my body was
wounded I would not feel for that pain
and I do in fact perceive this pain with
you know my sensation i if it weren't
the case I would only I would only see
the wound with my understanding sort of
like a pilot observes what's going on
with their ship instead I feel it
through this body so he goes on and he
says that you know when my my body has
need to drink or or eat I know this
simply by itself without having to be
warned by these confused sentiments and
he says in effect all these these
feelings of thirst and hunger and pain
are nothing other than certain confused
manners of thinking which arise out of
and depend on the Union and as it is as
it were the mixture of the mind with the
body so nature teaches us that we
actually do have bodies that we are in a
certain respect our bodies by being
connected with them so closely it also
teaches us that other bodies exist and
he says that nature teaches us that
there are other bodies around that that
of my own among which I should pursue
some of them and flee others I also
sense different sorts of colors odors
flavours sounds heat hardness etc and
all of the things of those sort from
this I can conclude that there are in
these bodies from which Purse precede
these different perceptions of the sense
some something in there he says
calculate a right some qualities
something in there some difference from
which these these arise and to which
they they respond even though they might
not be exactly the same
thing as exists in my mind he does
caution us however there are some things
that nature appears to be teaching us
but isn't actually teaching us instead
were the ones who are making the
contribution by as he says our habits of
inconsiderate judgments right a certain
he says a certain custom that I have of
in considerably that is you know not
paying close enough attention judging
things and he says so I can it can
easily happen that they contain some
falsity so what's an example of this one
of the interesting ones that Descartes
was connected with was this controversy
about can there be a vacuum in nature
Descartes thought there couldn't there
there was always going to be some sort
of particle this depends on his physics
which you can look at the principles of
philosophy to understand but he says you
know we look at things and you know we
think well there could be a vacuum there
but but really there couldn't if we
think about it carefully more
interesting and more importantly I would
say is this realization that he has that
he says in a body which is warm we think
that there's something similar to the
idea of heat which is in me strictly
speaking in my mind right that in a body
that's black or white there is the same
whiteness or blackness that I sense or
in a body that is bitter or sweet
there's the same taste or the same
flavor and so on with other things he
talks about the Stars as well you know
that which are very far away from us we
know this through the intellect you know
we think that they're like little candle
flames and that's not really the case
nature isn't teaching us those things we
are making a contribution to what nature
is providing us and drawing the wrong
conclusions and we could apply the same
sort of you know you could call it as
CSIS
or ethics of the use of the mind that
Descartes spelled out in meditation for
to avoid falling into those sorts of
errors and Descartes thinks that in fact
we should do that but we can say that
even if you know blackness or whiteness
are not actually in those things there's
something in them that is giving us that
sensation which that our mind translates
as those colors
likewise tastes and smells and things
like that so we actually learn quite a
bit from what Descartes calls nature
you